hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor
today we're going to talk about the
scientific method
the scientific method is simply a set of
techniques
used to ask and answer scientific
questions the scientific method starts
with making an observation
for example let's say that you go over
to a friend's house
and you start sneezing you also observe
that your friend has a dog then
it's time to propose a hypothesis
so you might hypothesize that you are
allergic
to dogs the next step is to conduct
an experiment
this may be when you go over to other
friends houses
who have dogs to see if you also have an
allergic reaction
following the experiment it's then time
to draw a conclusion
you may conclude that because you had
allergies in all of the houses of your
friends who had dogs
that you are allergic to dogs however
perhaps you visited some friends houses
where they had dogs and you had no
allergic reaction
if this happens depending on the
conclusion that you draw
you may find that you have to go back
and modify
your hypothesis that is if you found
that you weren't having allergic
reactions
in the presence of all dogs you may
think that you're only allergic to a
certain kind of dog
or perhaps the original friend who had
the dog also had
a cat or a specific kind of plant or
cigarette smoke or some other
environmental factor that could have
caused your allergies
so you see that the scientific method is
a cyclical
process you start at one end you go
through the different steps and
depending on the results of the
experiment
and the conclusion that you draw you may
have to go back
and formulate another hypothesis and go
through the process again
until you answer your original question
so that is the steps of the scientific
method i hope you learned a lot and
thanks for watching biology professor